hey who are you he looks like a soccer
mom
oh Dad You Gotta Lose the fanny pack I
Gotta Lose the ears
[Music]
all right I don't know how to pronounce
his name I tries Corey Corey Corey
k-o-u-r-i not Japanese Corey Richards
yep uh is a mother of three she called
the police late one night in March of
2022 last year and said her husband Eric
Richards was cold to the touch she told
authorities she had made her husband a
mixed vodka drink before finding him
unresponsive hours later oh my God a
medical examiner later found Mr Richards
died from a fentanyl overdose oh whoa he
had five times a lethal dosage of the
drug in his life
according to court documents between
December 20 21st and February 2022
Miss richens
had texted a person who had previously
been arrested on drug charges asking for
prescription pain medication for an
investor with a back injury Miss
Richards received hydrocodone uh
Hydro yeah hydrocodone that's what
Hydrocodone pills and the core document
said that before she requested something
uh she requested something stronger some
of the Michael Jackson stuff was the
quote oh sure she had to say that I
can't say that in quotes dude for
fentanyl oh I can't use the name of a
person that died from the thing yeah
three days after she allegedly obtained
the drugs she and her husband had a
Valentine's Day dinner after which she
felt ill Eric believed that he had been
poisoned the court document said Eric
told a friend that he thought his wife
was trying to poison him oh two weeks
later according to the documents Miss
richens acquired more Fentanyl and
prosecutors allege on March 4th Miss
richens called the police in the middle
of the night to say she had found her
husband unresponsive she had told
authorities he had served her she had
served her husband a mixed vodka drink a
Moscow meal and in bed and went to sleep
with one of her young children who was
having a night terror she later returned
to her husband in the room found cold to
the touch
now the really [__] up part about all
this
is that the charges came two months
after Miss riches wrote a picture book
called are you with me tell children
cope with the death of a loved one
so basically she
tried to capitalize off of the loss of
her husband that she murdered this big
business children's picture book wow for
her kids yeah and for kids in general
making money off oh good now they won't
have night terrors they need to cut her
head off and the book was apparently to
bring peace
is crazy this is when she's nuts someone
believes they're smarter than everyone
in the room goes wrong yeah that's true
you know like she thought I'm so smart I
could write a children's book about it
and then I'm gonna do it she tried to do
the OJ thing yeah I'm gonna make
millions of dollars only OJ could do it
yeah only O.J oh she didn't do the glove
didn't fit guys went to USC why would
you do that
this is one of those [__] that's so
crazy they got like two periods a month
that that perhaps when you're crazy
sometimes
her menstrual cycle is off the charts
is this one of those months you have two
periods
[__] yeah that's the thing you want to
say to her
no I have one and one's more than enough
have you do you know anybody that gets
two a month are you stupid there's a
couple that's what I'm asking the
authority I'm asking the authority in
the room dude that kind of [__] yeah you
could you could just smell a lady that
[__] has two of them yeah we probably
don't we probably don't know any that's
why I'm asking Colleen for research
purposes I think we don't know any of
those right do you no but there's also
such things as stupid
go to Starbucks my mom's
mom says there's like Alliance for women
to never answer that no you go to
Starbucks and if you see a ladies drink
with like seven adjustments too far from
the tree it was two or three of those
two or three menstruations if you're
getting caramel drizzle on your [__]
coffee in the morning I've seen people
do that and you're like bro what you're
getting caramel drizzle on a flat white
you know how like you know how like what
is that sounds good
you don't ask that out loud you you do
that in the privacy of your own home if
you just order drizzle yeah yeah dude
who does that what kind just drizzle any
kind of drizzle
this reminds me of that one uh dude who
like clearly murdered his wife or
whatever and he's like no I didn't do it
but then they searched his Google
history yeah oh yeah and it's every dumb
question how do you get rid of a body
yeah like do you do how long until
decomposed if you're okay guys honestly
if you're gonna ask that stuff you don't
know the answer go to like a a cafe that
doesn't have cameras and then type it in
there like don't type it on your home
computer or just go to a library cops
are gonna know the libraries have
cameras and they you have to put your
library card and they know it's going to
be you but like if you go to a cafe that
has like a bunch of computers and they
only have cameras you type that in there
they're not gonna know but that's how
Luca Magnotta got caught really because
the guy at the cafe recognized you
remember that yeah but Luka magnata is
like well he was narcissistic but if you
go in like this yeah dude no one will
know bro yeah who are you it looks like
the guy from you hey who are you he
looks like a soccer mom
oh Dad dude how [__] Incognito am I
You Gotta Lose the fanny pack I Gotta
Lose the ears you're literally I was
thinking about this the other day I was
like if I do a crime at all people are
gonna spot me for money no no headphones
what headphones You Gotta Wear
headphones don't even stay on my ears
Walter don't stop being insensitive they
don't stay on your ears yeah are you
[__] lying to me the only ones are
the Apple Max ones I put on my buddy's
beats and it was like my ears you could
see my ears let me see oh both
this is this is a hit or miss
seems like a hit to me they straight up
stay on you I never tried them but let's
definitely look like okay shoot out
don't they you need like glow sticks
does this guy you look like one of those
guys does he look like he's gonna visit
in Top Gun oh he looks like he's in them
yeah yeah yeah yeah like he's in the van
like like hacking into somebody's I'm in
it I need five more minutes
Seth Green an Italian job at the airport
so there's no yeah yeah there's no like
headphone Market where they're targeting
specifically cauliflower all right I
don't think so you should do that you
should call them the Nick I would go out
of business if I started that polyphones
hey there you go there's a lot of guys
that call it or girls too a lot of kids
actually everybody
freaks like that out there
Bart wanted to be inclusive who am I
miss you who am I missing gays and
blacks too A lot of people how would you
design a cauliflower ear headphone
they'd have to be really big I'll say
this I can't wear I used to love wearing
beanies but I can't wear beanies because
it looks like I'm just hiding something
in my beanie what do you mean because oh
are you wearing it over your ears I like
to wear it over my ears well that's your
fault then yeah am I doing it wrong you
probably should stop hiding you gotta do
the mic song barely a yamaka style yeah
like a little bit bigger than Yama yeah
I'm gonna try that that's the best and
you guys tell me what you got XL yamaka
that's the mic song
but I think other than that it's like
airpods fit pretty well yeah yeah why
are you so surprised you know they make
headphones now that you put on the
outside of your like right here really
it's called shocks s-h-o-k-z they're on
you got a promo code uh I do not if I
did though I would give it to you guys
part of your year and then you can you
can hear and you can also hear the
outside too really yeah
do you know most headphones you can't
hear the outside yeah but doesn't that
like kind of make it confusing because
you don't know what you're listening to
yeah it's true I think two bucks right
there but I feel like that's more of a
YP than a like a MP like a more of a
your problem than a microwave
I was like what the man
you guys ever uh not necessarily commit
a full-on crime as you like look up do
something wrong and then blame it on
somebody else
like like when you crop test somebody
that's how I got kicked out of third
grade
I don't know what's more interesting
that or the crop dusting crop dusting
yeah we've all been there I told you the
story about what happened in my high
school with that dude that got kicked
out because of the Cherry Bomb yeah
um that was that one
you're the one that did it I didn't do I
didn't do anything in all this whole
stuff it happened around me but like a
friend of mine put A little M80 in the
bathroom in high school and it blew up
the ceiling and then your friend Joe
figured out how to blame it on this like
foreign student oh wow he got sent back
oh my God he should have been so
offended told me though that whenever
it's my friend did this it's them that
actually did it
I'm not following who smelled the Delta
yeah yeah
they but they they blamed it on him
because his foreign student was super
creepy and he was like really like bad
to the girls where was he from to like
particularly damn um
Indonesia really yeah interesting I
thought they're all gentlemen over there
yeah but they're all Yoshis
everyone guess not they have good
chicken Indonesia oh yeah they do at
least that's how I understand the story
to be but yeah it definitely wasn't his
fault it was yours yeah no it was mine
either it was it was his friend
yeah five in the third grade I'm holding
it for a friend third so I have like OCD
and then um we were doing I was at a
private school and you have to uh do
this like art where it's like um you rip
out uh construction paper so if you want
to use Brown you can't use a brown
marker you take like brown construction
paper and you piece it all together but
I have OCD and I don't like rough edges
so every single piece of paper I would
fold and go like that Lit and then rip
it like this and then the teacher
specifically said no scissors so we're
trying to recreate like Jesus in a
stable type thing and then
um I I made mine I turned it in and the
teacher was like I said no scissors I'm
like it's it's not scissors she goes
you're staying in during recess
and then I already hated this [__]
teacher so I saw a turquoise crayon so I
grabbed the crayon I wrote [__] you Mrs
clinkenberg on the clock dumb name dude
clinking version that's a fake name and
I was the only and only student in there
during recess and then the teacher comes
and she's like who did this and then I
pointed at the guys are star athlete and
he's stereotypically the ethnicity you
think he is
[Laughter]
so she's racist and she
and share her construction without
scissors dude that's kind of sad that
you really took the time to rip it that
nice and you got accused for using and
I'm like I'm trying to you know you're
trying to race towards recess so I'm
having OCD we're all trying to do it
twice as fast as all the other kids
because all the other kids are like
right and then like they're just gluing
whatever I'm trying to like go really
fast because I still want to make it to
recess because you got to stay in and I
was just so [__] pissed what a
[__] [__] clankenburg yeah what a
stupid idiot right dead by now at least
[Music]